years
trying to box out and beat and there is
some
back and forth between these two teams
it's getting chippy kd and mv
exchanging words and i think this does
go back to the last meeting between the
two teams and there might be some deeper
history of course
double technicals have been assessed
and durant came walking right towards
embiid
the officials got in between so did
lamarcus aldridge
and they're still john
well and everyone has been drawn this
whole game i mean there's been a lot of
conversation
between players on the floor the benches
both sides
some note
you love to see these two teams see a
lot of each other hit
the sixers get to the finish line and
now embiid motioning in a similar
fashion to what durant did
the last time these two teams met
philadelphia 110 the nets 102.
[Music]
these guys don't forget
[Applause]
[Music]
anything the question is it fun and
games
aldridge and embiid are okay
durant is not going to exchange
pleasantries with any of the sixers
double thumbs up from kevin durant to
joel embiid
and philadelphia